the time it's true when people said
Wireless they actually would have said
the wireless despite the fact that
Wireless is a oh well this is an
adjective
right but when it first started going
into popular language it was a noun
okay because what I was referring to was
this oh yeah the way this was the
wireless people would say turn the
wireless on or did you hear it on the
wireless or the reports on the wireless
are you don't saying this that the other
right particularly around the first
world war
radio technology was just starting off
and this is the the first way that you
could transmit a signal wirelessly right
apart from you know say Morse code and
just like lights and that kind of thing
so this was the wireless okay
but now things have changed there's so
many different kinds of technology that
can link things without wires so that's
what we're going to go through today the
different clouds now as I go through
them the order that I'm going to take
them in is generally order of distance
so I'm going to go from small distances
very nearby and I'm going to expand down
from there okay so the very first one I
admit it's not very common these days a
small number of mobile phones have them
but we actually mentioned this yesterday
the first kind of wireless technology is
infrared okay now we don't tend to
associate this with our communication
systems like I said they're not a
comment in mobile phones or computers
that kind of thing a laptop I bought
many many years ago had an infrared port
on the side it's kind of not very common
because well if you're if you're going
to send it sort of like city light
signals but they're infrareds and we
can't see them right but as a result
because it's basically a kind of kind of
light it requires line-of-sight okay
line of sight and because it's light and
it's also very low energy light its
infrared if you didn't know let's
actually woke it up when you think about
the different kinds of light
sorry that's a good one ah this is that
this is the not clicking thing again
let's try it again
excuse me
so here you've got the spectrum of
visible light right and red is over one
end and violets over the other as you go
from at least on this one as you go from
right to left you're going from lower
energy to higher energy okay you also go
into I feel there's smaller - smaller
wavelength yeah smaller and smaller
wavelengths which is why early CD
players right they use sort of red
lights but as we move forward do you
know our blu-ray is called blu-ray it's
cuz the laser is blue it's more higher
energy it's a smaller wavelength and so
it can read smaller pits and lands on
DVD cubes not DVDs or blu-rays anyway
that was a side note so my point was
infrared is like here but below so if it
goes from low energy to high energy this
means it's quite low energy so these
signals they don't last very long right
so therefore when you think about
infrared the distance tends to be less
than 10 meters that's kind of a
theoretical limit in practical terms
it's usually even less than that
okay now infrared still get to use the
fair bit it's just in much lower
technology kind of devices like this
right so most remote controls that you
use they have this little thing on the
front right and it's line of sight so if
I cover it and I press the button
nothing's happening to the air
conditioner right now but if I I'm not
going to because it'd be a waste but if
I could point it and I was close enough
it would work right because it's using
infrared TV remotes DVD Rhodes they're
all the same
okay all right so this is the first kind
of wireless technology infrared like I
said not that common but